[Music]
this
golden algae is swimming around in water
and
white light illuminated from below using
a bright field microscope
and here we have that malamuna sample
filmed a day later using a different
technique
thanks to a brand new freshly installed
microscope when james our master of
microscopes
saw them for the first time he got a
little emotional because
to quote him directly the thing i know
so well
was looking so so much
different than usual
[Music]
those differences in how the malamonas
look
are due to a type of microscopy called
differential
interference contrast or dic
earlier this year james started a
crowdfunding campaign to purchase a new
microscope one that would allow him
to use differential interference
contrast to produce
these images you are seeing now now
technically differential interference
contrast
is not a type of microscope rather it's
a method
that enhances contrast and as you can
see
the final product is an image that seems
almost three-dimensional just watch this
stenter coroulius as it swims across the
slide its
cilia are so prominent that it almost
feels like you can
touch their vibrating fuzziness and the
striations down its body are so
sharp that when the center contracts
it's like you can feel it pushing inward
and then
back out again
differential interference contrast
microscopy
was invented by georges nomarski in 1952
building off the principle's underlying
phase contrast microscopy which is a
different though similar thing but both
of these methods work
to translate invisible shifts in light
phase that can happen when studying
certain samples
into visible changes in the light
amplitude
which we see as changes in light
intensity
and as a result both techniques enhance
contrast
and let us see parts of the microcosmos
that might be invisible with regular
bright field microscopy
but phase contrast microscopy and dic
shift and work with light in different
ways to accomplish this
goal how do they do it well
if you've ever taken an optics course
you will remember how terrible that was
but very basically phase contrast and
dic
are two ways to take advantage of a
strange
reality light actually travels
further through some materials than
others
kinda the optical path length is a
function of both
the distance between two points and
the refractive index of the material the
light
is traveling through basically
denser samples have longer optical
path lengths phase contrast microscopy
takes advantage of that
making areas with longer optical path
lengths
look darker the ic on the other hand
doesn't make areas that are denser
darker
it uses some very cool optics to create
sharp contrast in areas of rapid
change in the optical path length
so the faster the gradient from more to
less
dense or vice versa the more contrast
you see but it's also important to note
that while these images are the result
of light
traveling through a sample they are not
an
actual topographical map of an organism
dic microscopy is a technique but it
does require
certain physical additions to a
microscope for one thing
we need to split light apart so first
we have a prism that splits polarized
light into two
orthogonal rays of light that will then
pass through the sample and interact
with it in different ways
and then there's a second prism that
recombines those two rays
after they've traveled through the
sample forming an image
based on the differences those two beams
of light experienced
for our eyes and cameras to see
in addition to these prisms this
technique relies on having higher
quality objectives
than what we've been using in the past
the objectives are the
little lenses at the bottom of the
microscope that actually do
most of the magnification not many
people would realize this but
the objectives we use for journey to the
micro cosmos are some of the
cheapest and most common types of
objectives they're known as
achromatic objectives but while these
objectives produce
so many of our favorite images
james needed a microscope update to be
able to do
differential interference contrast so
with help perhaps including some from
you
james bought a new zeiss microscope
it took eight weeks for it to arrive
which is a long time to wait
but luckily the manufacturers sent him
a 150-page manual to occupy his time
until it arrived when the microscope
finally showed up
james still had to wait for an engineer
to install the nearly 50-pound machine
but he didn't waste any time james went
out
to gather his precious melamonis and
prepared a slide that night
keeping it stored in a humidity chamber
so that he could look at it
as soon as the microscope was ready the
next day
the zeiss engineer took three and a half
hours
to put all the pieces together and set
everything up
but from there well it was all on james
to observe what he could and experiment
with his new microscope
some of his experimenting has been
geared towards
making sure that he can get the best
image possible
these objectives have a much smaller
working distance compared to our
previous ones
and so you need to prepare the slides a
lot thinner to get a sharper
image so even for our master of
microscopes there was
somewhat of a learning curve to make
sure he was getting videos
that were as sharp and vivid as he
wanted
but some of the experimenting is based
out of that most exciting
thing of all curiosity he's removed some
of the prisms to see how it affects the
footage and added a magnifying glass
over the light source
to scatter the light in different ways
that's the joy of the micro cosmos
it is so infinite there's its own
objective existence full of so many more
organisms than we'll ever be able to
identify
but there's also the infinite nature of
how we
experience it of how our own
view of this world is shaped by the many
different
tools we use to observe it
and maybe that's the case all the time
that what we see
is as much about how we view the world
as it is about the world itself
the same thing with a different lens a
different technique a different
base of knowledge can look completely
different
as we start our third season of journey
to the micro cosmos
we hope you will continue to join us
through both our new
and old lenses as we uncover more
of this hidden unending world
thanks for coming with me on this
journey as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and guess what
we have new merchandise we have algae
socks
we also have a new coloring book so you
can spend a little time with your
favorite microbes
relaxing zoning out letting yourself
just be for a little while
thank you of course to all of these
people on the screen right now they
are our patrons on patreon these folks
are what make this channel possible if
you'd like to join
them in supporting us check us out at
patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes
james weiss you can check out jam and
germs on
instagram where you can see more great
stuff from his new microscope and if you
want to see more from us
there is always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby